plus qui est ce qui se passe en
martinique à voir que la circulation
reprend que tout le monde peut son
activité que que des magasins riz ou
alors que la conclusion que le
confinement est finie alors que non tout
au contraire le confinement doit être
plus intense ce n'est pas fini il faut
qu'on fasse attention et qu'on respecte
les règles cette inquiétude le docteur
joseph auguste la partager au quotidien
avec deux autres médecins généralistes
depuis plusieurs jours la population
martiniquaise semble ceux des conflits
nés avant l'heure
l'ust circulation des rues plus
fréquentée par les piétons et devant les
magasins autorisés à ouvrir des clients
de plus en plus nombreux une réalité qui
inquiète ses médecins
l'économie ne sauvera pas l'ouverture de
ce magasin sur le plan économique
puisque ça permet de sauver comme je
vous ai dit bon emploi payé des choses
la martinique abrite une population à
risque très sensible aux convives 19
diabétique hypertendue asthmatiques
population vieillissante des réalité
insoutenable que ces médecins
considèrent comme autant d'arguments
pour convaincre de rester chez soi un
personnage pratique à des poumons
fragiles
si vous imaginez qu'un patient qui est
déjà assez pratique donc à lire des
difficultés respiratoires vient encore
attraper le gros navires us vous
imaginez bien que vu le nombre de
patients on à matignon asthmatiques ou
vers la catastrophe
culturellement les bars mais qu'elle
aime bien les chocs pichot vanille vous
promenez vous attraper le virus
vous ramenez chez papy joannie demers il
arrive ce qui est déjà arrivé ici aura
déjà une grand mère qui est morte de
cela
demain vous allez vous sentir un peu
coupable donc vous les mettez un nouveau
cette alerte restée confinée respecter
le confinement
jusqu'au 11 mai et on verra trois
médecins qui craignent pour l'avenir si
les martiniquais continue à ceux des
conflits nés avant l'heure